>>> VERY
YONE.ENING,
YET ANOTHESUVI PCO ORAN TOOK OF
PRESIDENT,TE FIG
SUBPOENA THA THA
HE NO RIGHT TOAV.SE NOTESCORC M.
A SPECIAL UNSMITH.JOININUSS JOH
FOR RICHD
ANE EVANJOHN, YOU TESTIFIED ABO
CONVERSATIONWIN TO WT HAS
MIND, WHY WOE EVEN BDOZENS OOFEI
AT CONVERSIOEE CLITY SHORT? WEL
HIS WHE WE
NOTES.I DIDN'T TAKE NOTEWHITE HN
E ICH FORTUNATELY WAS
SUT  WAS A LITTLE ,
SQUIRRELY, A HW
O AS REPORTED VERY DETAILED
SUCHL
EXPRESSION
>> IT DOES SEEM TO SUGGEST THAT
CORCORAN HAD A SENMELLY GOINBA B
DE. THINK THACORCOR
HA TRYG
PEROTECT HIMSELF?
GOOD REASON TO
SUT  TE.
I THN'T OWHA AT
K VALUAEN PROSECUTORSHAT THCOUT
WA OUNSEL TO COMMIT A CRIME.D T
'SY SACRED'T LIKTO
RE VERY AWARE OFT,SPECTATORS A I
T IME/FRAUEXCEPTION WAS FOUND B.
HE WOSE TO
WHT WHETHER OR T TRUMP ARE SAE I
NOT THEY COULD FIGHT THE
SUBPOENASO, OUA PRUTU'RE E,
HOW DO YET IE  TMPTR JUSTICE,
ASKING HOW TO GET OU TRUMP, YOU.
TRUMP AYING VIS CAN THAT MOMENT.
I THINK  I AID
ESTING H
>> AS I PIECE TOGETHER THE
REPORTING, WHAPE HAVE
K PPENED IS HEIGGI
LAWYTURED IT WITH
SOMEONE ELSEPE MOVED DOCUMENTS
OF THATHE SUBPOENA BEING
VERED ANEDHE SORT OF TTHAT THEST
OTS
WILLFUL L ER IT'S T S THOBSTRUC
THIS POINT.
>> TRETHER DETAIVE
WE'R FROE YORK TIMES."
E REPT OR A
NESSES ISERY RIES N CHINA,
EM OMAN. DOES IT SAY TT DEALS TT
BACKHRENCY ING THLOOKING TO SEE
TO D
WHAT H IN THE
IN NE IN THE
WHEN HE GAVE A SFYNF
WHICE THING.T HEREYOU KNOW, I T-
MYTEMAHIATN
HALL, , HAVE YR
SHARED ANY OF THIS ANYBODY?ST P
WOULD HA GAS
DIDN'T NATIOCURITY
INS ANDON'T
IT'S NOT SURPRISIN THESPECIAUN
WHO THEN
AN DEALI WATHAT HE COULDE HIS I?
VE MIGHT
E INFORMN?S
VE, AS YOU JUST TANT TO KEEP TH
SAIDNE OF THE OTR
LEGAL CASES HE FORMER
PR EMBROILED IN.IS IS DEALAN MA
ASSAULT CASE AINIT SEEMSSH
TONDS CASE BASED ON HI CNN TOWN
LIST T. THET RAPE
Y DIDN'T --
DIDN'T DO ANYTHING EITHER BECA
DON'T WA IT KE STORY, AND YOIS
CREDIBY. WHY I DIDN'T GO.
Y-  AND IAR
THATA WHE HELL --
JOB.
>> SHE'S A WHACKOBAT DO YOU MAK?
AT ALL.
IT WAS FIL.A NEW CASET WA
IGNT THA
N NOVEMBER OF 2019 THAT
HAS BEEN BOUNCING AR  OVER WHRES
ANATITE UPAPPEALS AND W ESIDENT
IT'S BACK DOWN IN THE DISTRICT
COUR'S WHE SHE THERE.
AND ITDAMAGE
HE'S VERY VVNOWSING
MOVINK TRUMP COD UP  ANOTHERE
MILLIO